steve kerr played on two title teams
from popovich both really impacted
in their lives both basketball and off
the court as thompson knocks down the
three 1
36 wins and jack you know how much many
you contributed to pop
as clay thompson
hits another three paul deflects it
picks it up paul looking to push pull to
thompson thompson tries again puts it in
play thompson on fire all of a sudden
time out milwaukee
thompson finds bialitza ali up to
kaminga comes down with it now shoots
over there
the eliza tips it right to thompson
another three
flames
lighting it up here in the second
quarter
easy layup
and good back tip here
for the leaning
three by thompson
he is flat out working his tail off he
should be awarded
it was great to see the smile on their
faces
yeah true joy
thompson for three clay thompson his
sixth three-pointer
curry simple left-hand
pass holiday a step late on the closeout
cross court thompson catch fires
play thompson from downtown
[Music]
draymond green will be back monday he's
loving what he's seeing from klay
thompson and here's what i'm talking
about the extra pass made by clay by
steph curry to clay thompson knocks it
down look on the opposite side
clay thompson recognizing i'm a bad man
well the quickness of that release the
ball
pool goes back door whips the past
owings up top tops in another three bang
play thompson pouring it on he's got 35.
it doesn't even bring the ball down no
this is
this is fascinating right here
he gets it off so quickly
and this is good
cotted high kept it high